if you can sit next to Howard Schultz in
a board meeting which I do and every I
sit as close as I can Riis on me give me
a little bit on them because if you
don't go and watch video from when you
win you watch video from when you lose
it was one of those things where you
think you're going to go in and you
going to make a pitch and they're
totally going to shoot you down and then
ultimately they say yes and you're like
Hello believe nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems so to
help you on your journey today we're
going to learn from Ariel Investments
president Mellody Hobson and my take on
our top ten rules of success rule number
ten is my personal favorite and I'd love
to know which one you guys liked the
best
and as always as you're listening if
something really resonates with you
there's a message that really holds true
to you please leave it down the comments
below and put it in quotes so that other
people can be inspired and when you
write it down it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well enjoy
via Sanada Warren Buffett quickly
interviewed people and he says are you a
fanatic and when you need systematic to
know them and I don't seem to Matic in a
bad way you know it's this the people
that have most admires have so loved
their work and so one of the good
outcomes understand why they're so
successful and when I think about our
young leaders of color I want to tell
them just you know it's
you think it's the printer itself it
never gets easier I'm still doing from
work every weekend and still it never
gets easier and if anything the stakes
go up so much you actually have to work
even harder you have to be cynical you
do not give up they don't leave it so
personal you figure out how you're going
to get out do not let people talk you
out of your dreams do not let them tell
you now and you old that you have to do
them I spend time with people who are
world class I know what world class
looks like and I have to bring that back
to my organization and bring that to
life for them but I can tell you with
the people that I spend time with I am
learning world-class from them yeah and
so therefore I have big dreams if you
can sit next to Howard Schultz in a
board meeting which I do and every I sit
as close as I can breeze on me you feel
a little bit of that you know look my
way now I'm joking but I said you know
because I want to I am watching how he
watches how we how we studying how the
presentation is being made how is
interacting with people and I am
learning and I want to make sure our
people have that same level of energy
around us that's because that's what
world classes do not make any decisions
based on money none it's the worst way
to make a decision which I know it's so
hard to say I mean I didn't grow up with
any money and I know so many of us are
our families have a lot of stake they
put a lot into us made a lot of
sacrifices for us and you say you don't
have the luxury of doing that but I
actually think you do you will be more
successful if you make decisions based
upon what is going to feed your soul
make you skills value valued validated
you know have you waking up in the
morning and waiting to work whatever it
might be and I can tell you after a
short amount of time money will not be
enough at the end of the day a bigger
paycheck is another suit or more real
estate more square footage that's when
it comes down to you end up with another
room
and a fuller closet and after a while
that's not going to do it I read this
quote from during in knodel an obituary
for Floyd Patterson the boxer and he
said said he only learned from losing a
fight he said you don't go and watch
video from when you win you watch video
from when you lose and it is the
failures that build the character that
make you smarter stronger tougher I
always tell people with scars are
smarter and I think that is a really
good thing to be you can build on all of
that accumulated knowledge in a way that
can serve you and your client care
company very very well but there have
been you know numerous moments of great
pause and reflection where I set and say
and I say to our team and I say to
myself what is the universe trying to
teach me good idea of I'm not looking
out five years I'm looking at long term
I'm not thinking about there's another
job for me somewhere off I'm thinking
about this job right now those are the
kind of things that you know I think
have been able to lead to my success
when I started working in Arial our
founder John Rogers said something to me
that I've never forgotten on my very
first day he took me do TGI Fridays big
spender and he said every game in life
is one with patient every single one and
he said I don't care if it's dating -
you can't win the Indianapolis 500 in
the first lap - a basketball game he's
like if you look at all sports just a
very simple just one sort of portion of
the world patience is how you win and
that isn't something that I intuitively
thought at that moment I think when I
think about what I'd like to be
remembered for I would like to be
thought of having been very kind
who did right by society I actually
learned that probably in my most
formative years from my business partner
John Rogers I actually just read a
graduation speech that someone gave at
one of the universities about kindness
and I thought that he really spoke to
everything that John started to tell me
when I was 22 that you could always take
the kind path and you could win with
kindness and I tried to think a lot
about that and it doesn't always work
and sometimes I know I'm not as kind as
I want to be but it's in the back of my
mind a lot I said in a lot of rooms with
people who wait wait for someone to say
something or my favorite line is I give
this all the time at Princeton we had a
professor and if you were in a precept
group with him and someone spoken you
said I want to reiterate what Sally said
he would say you mean iterate again
which meant you have no original thought
and so it's one these are the kinds of
things I think about have an original
idea be willing to speak it because it
will get you notice I love to swim so
much that as an adult I swim with a
coach and one day my coach had me do a
drill where to swim to one end of a 25
meter pool without taking a breath and
every single time I failed I had to
start over and I failed a lot by the end
I got it but I got to the pool I was
exasperated and tired and annoyed and I
said why are we doing breath holding
exercises and my coach looked at me and
he said melody that was not a breath
holding exercise that drill was to make
you comfortable being uncomfortable
because that's how most of us spend our
days if we can learn to deal with our
discomfort and just relax into it we'll
have a better life I think there was a
very specific risk that I took very
early on it eriell that was unique and
unprecedent at the time I was about 24
years old I'd been there for a couple of
years and we had these public mutual
funds that were in partnership with
another company and I went to our board
of directors and said we need a divorce
it had never happened before and we
pulled a crop apart to operating mutual
funds from an existing mutual fund
family 400 million dollars in assets
paid four million dollars for the right
to do it it was the whole nest egg of
the company
and that was a very very very bold call
at the time it was one of those things
where you think you're going to go in
you're going to make a pitch and they're
totally going to shoot you down and then
ultimately they say yes and you're like
[Laughter]
no I don't know what I'm doing
but it ended up like marrying me to the
company right it's where Ariel became
mine right now on a day-to-day basis
what I'm now pushing very hard and
Catherine Berardi is with me who is my
new teammate at Ariel and a spectacular
superstar and she's serving I'll say
this story like 100 times and for months
but my new thing that I'm really pushing
very very hard especially with women and
my friend Sheryl Sandberg is also doing
the same thing in her own magnificent
way I can't even compare myself because
she has a book that's coming out on this
idea but I feel like as women the risk
is us speaking our truth and the story
that I'm now been telling as a story
that I read about a woman in a magazine
who said every single day every single
day her daughter walked out of the house
starting when she was a very small child
she said the exact same thing to her
every single day through college be
brave
every single day she said she wrote her
letters in college and she always signed
them be brave and that now just speaks
to me because I'm in so many rooms where
I feel like the courage is not always
there and I don't know what the fear is
maybe it's the fear of not saying the
right thing or not fitting in but I'd
rather the person totally you know make
a giant mistake did not say anything at
all and I just find with women sometimes
we're really sort of waiting to add our
voice and I don't mean to say this in
any way that diminishes us because we
have the good ideas but you know I when
I was at Princeton in our precepts our
small groups when we weren't in lecture
they would say something to you that if
you were piling on with what someone
else said and you say I'd like to
reiterate what this person said they say
oh you mean iterate again
and that was their way of making you see
like that is not an original thought and
I feel like a lot of the women in the
room have the original thought in some
situations and are waiting to be
validated and I'm just like go for it go
for broke pound the table speak your
truth and I now notice it in ways even
in my own firm where I give people
real-life examples we had a board
meeting recently at our firm and one of
my colleagues who's a superstar woman
was presenting and she was only looking
at our CEO when she was talking and I
was like don't ever do that again
it was like she was looking for his
validation and all the other people
around the table it was like they didn't
matter and I was like it just made you
look small and you're not and that was
like a simple example of that being
brave what about her needed to lock on
in him and have him not and you know
have her keep going versus just owning
the room with her present I end up for
you what you believe in do not back down
and that doesn't mean you have to do it
with a fist in the air or you know with
with with aggression you can do it with
grace and I cannot be talked out of what
I believe now that doesn't mean like in
my core values you cannot convince me
that racism will ever be a path to
something good you cannot convince me
that excluding people has ever leads to
a better outcome you cannot convince me
of that I will not be moved I will not
compromise that point of view and as a
result of that I'm going to do
everything I can to keep pressing those
perspectives and I think if any any
issue I have with some of the lower
nails that I've had the opportunity to
work up close with don't be compliant
you know just you know you're taught
sometimes winning is the path of least
resistance and I think this is now more
than ever your voice and you know being
being willing to put yourself in harm's
way it's like the question of losing a
job I know it counts like I'm being flip
I've often asked myself do I belong here
should I walk out nothing is worth us
and you know I think that you know just
really pushing yourself to understand
that sometimes certain things you're
just going to have to walk away if you
really really really believe that you've
got to stand up for something so you
know I was I went to this program at the
Aspen Institute at the Henry cron
fellows program we were in these small
leadership groups 20 people and skip
faddle who's this amazing guy and known
in Silicon Valley with my moderator as
so much respect and admiration for him
and one day we were in the room and he
said to me melody I know you will do
good I was like thirty years old he goes
but will you stand in harm's way
will you put yourself in harm's way he's
like you could go through your whole
life just doing the easy path and
feeling good about yourself and patting
yourself on the back but when you allow
yourself to be hurt will you allow
yourself to have a tremendous setback
because you stood up for what you
believed and that forced me to really
think about the path of least resistance
and saying versus believing that I will
allow myself to be harmed and then I
started to think about people like John
Lewis standing on the Edmund Pettus
Bridge and I start to think I literally
cannot even say this without lowing up
saying could I have that kind of courage
and I think this is the moment we're
standing in right now we have to have
that John Lewis courage that Martin
Luther King courage that dogs turned on
teenagers fire hoses turned on people
courage because I think that if we were
standing there by were standing there I
think I would run and now I'm telling
myself stand
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Sarah green
asked me to is there someone you like me
to profile in the next top 10 check out
the link in the description and go and
cast your vote I'd also love to know
what was your favorite message from this
video what did you learn from this video
that you're going to immediately apply
somehow in your life or in your business
please leave it down the comments below
I'm really curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shout out to the
SOT no artist YouTube channel thank you
guys so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word and having me on your
show in an interview to talk about it I
really really really appreciate the
support and I'm so glad that you enjoyed
the book we're interviewing author of
your one word Evan Carmichael live on
our YouTube channel so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
if you follow your passion you're going
to be successful no matter what because
one you'll be happy and I think
happiness is really important you can't
do anything well if you're not happy you
can't be a good parent good spouse
girlfriend boyfriend you can't be a good
co-worker happiness is important and
that doesn't mean you for you everyday
but a basic sense of peace and for some
of us especially type-a and especially
people are hard on ourselves we don't
give each other give ourselves a break
and so the pursuit of happiness as we
have it written obviously in our
Declaration of Independence is something
that is challenging so pursuing
happiness I do think is important as a
pursuit of anything else observe your
environment at work at school at home
I'm asking you to look at the people
around you purposefully and
intentionally invite people into your
life who don't look like you don't think
like you don't act like you don't come
from where you come from and you might
find that they will challenge your
assumptions and make you grow as a
person you might get powerful new
insights from these individuals however
our best ideas also come from pushing
something that other people are afraid
to do so we've innovated in areas that
cause people some trepidation and I
think that's just the part of us a
little irreverent and the part of us
that's willing to be very very different
everything's I'm having a turtle of the
logo when Meryl has been a theory ball
and Dreyfuss has a lion and we have this
turtle holding a loving talk of the
drawing and you know look very friendly
that was very different so we have this
turtle it was John's original logo for
Ariel and then we just blew it out I
mean all of our materials look like
storybooks and our Rocher was like a
storybook and people would get them and
say I took this home and then you knew
you had something special